Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to look at some basic lighting and shadow concepts when it
comes to building your worlds in Unreal.
So let's get started.
So in the scene that we were messing with and just throwing things together and building
a quick simple scene, I'm going to actually gut the lighting here, and I'm going to show
you how this works.
But one thing I do want to point out before I do that, you'll notice my clouds are very
unique.
Well, that happened because I edited them in such a way so that I could use and create a
little bit more stylized volumetric clouds.
This is a pretty easy procedure.
This is a little bit out of the box.
I went and grabbed a soft profile, and I made an instance of that particular material.
In that material, I wouldn't mess with the settings involved.
So you can see here that I messed with the density, I messed with the detail, and
I messed with detail too.
And down below, you'll see that pretty much everything's kind of standard par, but you
definitely can go in here and play with these a little bit more.
But this gave me more of the fluffy cloud look in here.
Oh, unfortunately, we're going to have to gut everything.
So let's go to our directional light first.
Let's get rid of that.
We want to get rid of our skylights and our sky atmosphere.
Let's get rid of those.
And we also want to get rid of our cloud.
And finally, we want to get rid of our fog.
There we go.
So all three of those are gone.
Now the reason why I'm doing this is I want to show you a quick way to get spun
up that a lot, not a lot of people are aware of.
You want to go to Windows environment light and mixer, the environment light mixer gets
you up and running in your lighting really quickly.
We can set it to minimal, normal or normal advanced.
This just gives us some more options, as in the details for control.
So I'm going to click on create skylight.
I'm going to create a click on create directional light.
Now you'll see a warning at first, because it needs the sky atmosphere for the skylight.
So I'm going to create directional light, I'm going to create sky atmosphere.
And then finally, I'm going to create these last two, which is create volumetric cloud,
and then volumetric height fog.
There you go.
You're up and running.
Now, even though we have the light mixer, we can do some editing, you can also do it
here by selecting the outliner and be able to edit your light the way that you want.
I'm going to be breaking these classes up in a couple of sections, more than likely
going to be three.
And the reason why is because there's a lot to cover with lighting in some very important
factors involved.
One of the first things you want to make sure we have is a post process volume.
Let's go and put one in.
I'm just going to type in post process volume, I can simply look up volumes, and place that
in the scene.
This post process volume is allowing me to control my exposure, as well as my overall
sweeping elements when it comes to Lumen.
We'll get back to that in just a second.
One of the first things we do want to make sure we do is we want to go to our
project settings.
Now, if you're using Lumen by default, if you're using Unreal by default, Lumen should
already be on.
But there are some things you need to keep in mind when you're getting things spun up.
So let's go to the rendering section here.
Under rendering, we want to go ahead and scroll down a bit.
And we want to look at our global illumination and what we are running for that.
In our particular case, we're using Lumen.
And in there, we also have a reflection method of Lumen.
You'll see underneath the Lumen surface catch, I have it as a basic surface catch here,
but that can change from our ray light mode.
I can change that to hit reflections for more accuracy if I need.
Those can be changed also via the post process volume.
You'll notice my software ray tracing mode is global tracing, that's basic, but I can
go into detail if I need more realism and more accuracy.
I'm keeping things pretty much for this screen tracing source, this scene color, and
that works just fine.
But you want to make sure that you are using hardware ray tracing when available,
and you support hardware ray tracing.
This will help with your geometry, especially if you're making them modulated and punching
them into each other for interiors and for exteriors to make sure you don't have
any light leaking or blotchy shadows.
This helps a lot when doing this.
If you're grabbing something from the marketplace, you want to make sure if it's an older scene
that has distance, mesh distance fields active.
And Unreal will give you, will do its best to remind you of those things that need to
be active if you're activating Lumen.
We also want to make sure that we have our SM6 active also, and you'll see that
mine is active.
You don't necessarily have to have Vulkan unless you plan on going in that direction.
But for the most part, we want to keep it here because the overhead, if you don't
need it, don't turn it on.
It's just not necessary.
Now I have a post process volume in place.
We want to go ahead and look at the overall sweeping control of this post process volume.
We want to make sure that's influencing as much of the world as we need.
Now this can be isolated.
I can isolate it based on shape.
Heck, I can even edit this if I wanted to.
And you can do so use brush editing.
You can control the shape on a point level on even a face type of level or edge.
But I simply just want it to be encompassing our whole world.
So I'm going to go to my post process volume settings, and I'm going to click on infinite
extend unbound.
That's going to make it so everything is in control.
Now when it comes to exposure, there are multiple ways to skin this cat is you can
turn on auto exposure histogram.
And you can have it so it's underneath a particular range.
And it auto changes based on where you are in the world.
So if I was moving around in dark areas, you'll see it lighten up.
I get in here, it lightens up, I go inside the cave.
And when I get out, it darkens enough to simulate what happens with the eye.
That happens a lot with a lot of games.
I personally sometimes like to have control if I'm not doing a first person type of
environment.
And to do so I could lock this down to one and lock this expose EV also to one.
And then I can simply turn on a comp comp exposure compensation.
Sometimes it's hard to say.
And then I can brighten this or darken this according to what I need.
Now we want to control the direction for sure.
Say this is a top down game.
And we want to make sure that we're we're getting the best lighting that we possibly
can get dramatic shadows pretty great.
Now I can keep it on this angle if I wanted to and that's actually kind of nice.
The only thing is do I want to soften my shadows or make them strong and sharp.
That's really up to you and how you want to convey your world.
And sometimes depending on the distance of the camera you may want to sharpen shadows
so that things may be a little bit clearer if you're doing like a third person or
a top down.
But that's really up to you and how you came and the mood that you want to set.
In this particular case if I wanted to do that underneath my directional light I can
go here and control my angle here called a source angle.
This will soften or sharpen my shadows.
Now because it's reflecting on water you're not going to see it as much but if we look
at the terrain you will see it a bit more in its changes.
We can really bump this up to get an overcast view or we can sharpen it and put it all
the way down to zero to get more of a harder shadow.
That's up to you.
The defaults kind of a little bit nice in between but you can play with that.
Now if you ever want to eliminate or actually hide some of your lighting we go over this
in basic lighting and what I mean by that is only affects certain sources.
Underneath advanced you'll see that there's a channel option where you can choose light
channels.
Every object has a light channel and every light has a light channel and you can just
make them correspond.
So I don't want to go off too much on that but let's go to the slides and let's take
a look at some of the settings that we have when it comes to working with Lumen.
So you should know this a bit from our introduction classes but Lumen likes to use Nanite in
virtual shadow maps.
This works great with this system.
I like to think of it as a three musketeers Lumen Nanite in virtual shadow maps and
the reason why is it actually is a efficient system that calls upon the visual fidelity
of the object and the shadow based on positioning in the world making things cheaper.
So Lumen achieves full resolution shading while computing indirect lighting cheaper
than before and it's getting better stronger faster.
Sky lighting is solved as part of Lumen's final gather process and includes sky shadowing
allows indoor space to be much darker than outdoor lighting much more natural effect.
So it actually works really really well.
And you'll see Lumen also provides a lower quality global illumination for lit, translucency
and volumetric fog.
So we can also manage a few things using the light mixer but we mainly were using
the environment light mixer to be able to call things up and get them into play.
Now you can choose between GPU and CPU based on your game.
I recommend GPU baking and CPU baking when it comes to mobile devices.
But if you're going to go for console or PC you may want to choose Lumen.
Again this really depends on your game and how realistic you want it to be in its environment.
Now the difference between them the main difference is these are baked shadows.
These are shadow maps and Lumen uses virtual shadow maps.
So GPU and CPU baking is baked shadow maps Lumen is virtual shadow maps and virtual shadow
maps are required that each light be movable and the shadow will update automatically.
You'll see a few of what I mentioned before in here.
We'll talk a bit about mega lights later on as that is experimental but that can allow
you to manage lots of lights in your scene.
So we talked about a bit of light mixer which allows to help you for management.
I also showed you an environment light mixer to be able to get up and running into your
lighting really quickly.
So in the next video we're going to talk about a bit of the control and we're going
to take an interior scene and we're going to light it.
Thanks again.